[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
t'es sûr que cet enfant et de moi même
dire c'est une interne en médecine très
prometteuse dans le métier je suis sûr
qu'elle est bourré de talent surtout que
c'est celle de tripoter de faire des
branler
ah vous êtes qui je suis venu pour
promener boris un bonjour vous êtes les
heureux parents le père est dans les
jupons dessus dit il essaie de se
remettre du traumatisme de mon
accouchement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
même si ça va mieux j'ai pas envie
d'être une mère célibataire
t'as jamais comme on peut parfois les
choses arrive cinq ont été scellées
quelqu'un peut s'occuper d'améliorer le
montage j'ai déjà vu tous les râches
donc ce serait plus logique que je
manquais mecheri qu'il reviendra et toi
tu dois en profiter pour tamiser mignan
c est aussi une dingue
waouh inspiration saint tropez
tu es orange a cru que le thème c'était
lâche et ç'a gauche que je vois tes
jolies couleurs
tu étais 10h15 j'ai envie du récit sont
attachés même d'annuler schyle corps des
pieds à la tête
vraiment peu pâle j'ai envie d'une
relation légère amusant et surtout
stewart
et à cause d'elle qui nous quitte et il
n'a jamais cessé de décrire
pour la première fois de ma vie je suis
ce que je fais et surtout je sais
pourquoi
et si peter revient laisse lui
on peut traquer la maison solide
soro
[Musique]
ils sont
ciao
la seigneurie d'albanie tôt alors mes
jolies princesses
vous aimez les bananas ouais je veux
bien faire un tour sur ta banane à ta
oublier baril non manana
saoudi
[Musique]